est
ce personnage
nous allons à bruxelles pour parler à
higgins stoltenberg et nous avons avec
nous le nôtre commentateurs douglas et
repères monsieur le secrétaire général à
jour merci de votre temps nous sommes
assez âgé pour nous rappeler de la
guerre froide des choses que nous
pensions inenvisageable il y a une
semaine sont aujourd'hui plausible
est-ce que vous pensez que cette guerre
pourrait s'étendre à un membre de l'otan
chaud chaud tout d'abord il est
impossible de ne pas être affectée
affligé quand on voit les images de
toutes ces souffrances en ukraine des
civils qui sont tués et les dégâts
terribles que nous voyons dans
l'ensemble du pays la responsabilité de
l'otan est de protéger et de défendre
tous ses alliés nous avons donc la
responsabilité de nous assurer qu'il n'y
ait pas d'escaladé au delà de l'ukraine
d'autres dans des pays de l'otan et
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
consolidé la présence de l'otan à l'est
de l'alliance sur terre dans la mer et
dans les airs il faut montrer à moscou
que nous sommes prêts à défendre nos
alliés et de préserver la paix et
d'empêcher toute attaque sur un membre
de l'otan youpine
vérité dit très clairement que l'otan
était une alliance défensive qu'elle
n'était pas l'agresseur dans ce conflit
qu'elle ne cherchait pas à être partie
au conflit est ce que vous êtes
préoccupé avec vous et associé de l'otan
sur la possibilité d'une confrontation
accidentelle qui entraînerait une
escalade involontaire bien sûr
ça paraît plausible vu ce qu'on a vu sur
le terrain avec le bombardement des
villes ukrainiennes la dîmière poutine
n'a pas besoin d'être provoqués pour
accuser le temps d'être l'agresseur
est ce qu'une confrontation accidentelle
est possible et pourrait entraîner une
escalade
mais il faut fournir tous les efforts
pour empêcher qu'un incident un accident
ait lieu et qui implique des alliés de
l'otan et si c'est le cas il faut
s'assurer que cela n'entraîne pas une
escalade ce qui serait encore pire que
ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui c'est à
dire une guerre totale qui impliquerait
l'otan et la russie
c'est pourquoi
je dis très clairement qu'il faut une
communication jeu des efforts pour
réduire le risque de conflit avec la
russie éviter le risque d'accident
d'incidents et de pouvoir les gérer s'il
arrive
notre priorité c'est d'appeler la russie
à mettre un terme à cette guerre est de
ramener ses forces et nous devons aider
l'ukraine
et éviter aussi une escalade dans un
membre de l'otan
la différence qui a demandé à l'europe
d'envoyer à son pays des avions de
chasse pour arrêter l'invasion russe
qu'en est il sur cette question et si
c'est le cas qui piloterait ses avions
alliés de l'otan ont fourni une aide à
l'ukraine depuis des années en
particulier depuis 2014 quand l'ukraine
a été envahie pour la première fois
les alliés ont formé des dizaines de
milliers de soldats ukrainien puis
enfourner des armes antichars
système de défense anti-aérien et des
militaires des équipements militaires et
tout cela a été très important parce que
ça a aidé les forces armées ukrainiennes
courageuse à résister à
l'envahisseur russes
et les armées kényanes sont beaucoup
mieux équipés et formés et beaucoup plus
grande qu'en 2014
nous continuerons à leur apporter un
soutien
je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails
du type de soutien que notre
organisation fourni mais renforçons
notre soutien pour lui
faisaient parler du soutien qui est l'un
des piliers de ce que l'otan peut faire
en ukraine puisque l'otan ne peut pas
envoyer de soldats sur le terrain alors
comment est ce que ces armes arrivent
sur les champs de bataille
logistiquement qui les emmène une fois
que ces armes sont dans les mains des
forces du craignent n combien de temps
faut-il pour que ces personnes puissent
utiliser les armes et les rendre
opérationnelles
je suis très prudent je ne veux pas
entrer dans le détail parce que ça peut
saper les efforts de nos alliés à
fournir une aide mais les alliés ont
annoncé que des équipements étaient
arrivés aux forces armées ukrainiennes
mais je ne vais pas entrer dans les
détails
parce que ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est que les alliés
apportent une aide
que nous aidions
les forces armées dans leur lutte
le courage dont je sais forces armées et
les populations font preuve montre le
courage et est aussi l'engagement de
zelensky et des leader ukrainien il est
très important de renforcer notre
soutien il faut apporte une aide
militaire mais aussi humanitaire et
financière
la situation nous montre
la situation dans laquelle l'otan se
trouve
qu est-ce que l'otan peut faire
sachant que tout ce que l'otan fait peut
entraîner une guerre beaucoup plus
grande et dangereuse
nous préparions à cette éventualité
depuis longtemps parce que les services
de renseignement de l'otan en
particulier des états unis ont dit que
cela pouvait arriver déjà il ya quelques
mois
on
cherchait à trouver une solution
politique mais le président poutine a
préféré utiliser
là la force contre l'ukraine et donc les
alliés depuis quelques semaines et mois
ont renforcé leur soutien pour l'ukraine
mais nous n'entrons pas dans le cren
avec les soldats ou les avions de l'otan
nous aidons l'ukraine à défendre leur
droit à la légitime défense qui est le
droit de n'importe quel état souverain
tel que prévu par la charte de l'onu
nous ne sommes pas partie au conflit
cependant ne déployons pas deux soldats
sur le terrain ou d'avions de l'otan
dans l'espace
r2 ministère des affaires étrangères
russe a dit que toute tentative de la
finlande de la suède de rejoindre
l'alliance de s'en rapprocher pourrait
avoir
des conséquences militaires et
politiques sérieuses comment réagissez
vous
c'est une déclaration inacceptable de la
part de la russie c'est contraire au
principe fondamental de la sécurité que
chaque état a le droit de choisir sa
voie s'ils souhaitent apprendre
appartenir ou non à une alliance comme
le tank
l'élargissement de l'otan a permis de
diffuser la démocratie et la liberté
dans l'europe depuis des décennies
depuis la fin de la guerre froide
je respecte le droit souverain de la
finlande la suède décider de leur avenir
je les respecte le souhaitent de ne pas
adhérer à l'otan mais s'ils font une
demande d'adhésion ils ont ce droit
c'est la finlande et la suède et l'otan
qui doivent décider de cela
et nous entendons de la russie que si
l'on ne répond pas à leurs exigences il
y aura des conséquences militaro
technique
c'est une manière de nous intimider de
nous menacer
des menaces et des états souverains en
europe la russie a cherché à avoir moins
de temps mais ils en obtiennent plus à
leurs frontières avec leur comportement
ils ont cherché à nous diviser ils nous
ont une
c'est notamment avec la finlande et la
suède qui sont des partenaires très
proches ils étaient présents à la
réunion aujourd'hui et cela montre que
la russie a obtenu le résultat contraire
de ce qu'il voulait c'est à dire plus
d'autant une autant plus fort c'est plus
d'unités à brouiller notre
dernière question à part le président
français qui parle à vladimir poutine y
at il une autre personne au sein de
l'alliance qui parle au leader russe
nous avons cherché à communiquer pour
réduire le risque de confier le risque
d'erreur
et les alliés
sont prêts à s'engager dans des
discussions politiques sérieuses mais il
faut par ailleurs que la russie
s'engagent dans des efforts
diplomatiques et jusqu'ici la russie a
choisi la guerre les forces armées
plutôt que des efforts diplomatiques
merci pour votre temps